[Music]
hey guys welcome to DL and model
lifestyle
I'm photographer Nikita join with me
motto youtuber and my husband Daniel
murids
hey guys what's up and today we are
doing a quest video from you guys for
model photoshoot tips for photographers
yeah
how many tips are you gonna give them
today I'm gonna give you my 7 based ones
all right cool shall we start yeah let's
go
and hey just so you know I'll add the
links of all the equipment that I'm
using in this video in the description
down below so be sure to check it out
okay so let's start with set number one
number one is when planning your photo
shoot guys when you do your research
please send some reference images to
your models why you might ask
remember the model needs to know what
the look and the feel and some of
outfits are the location that you're
going to shoot in they need to know what
is expected of them so they can go and
prepare some poses or explosions or
something like that
another do test shoots then they can
prepare their own outfits as well to fit
in like this and then remember to do
location scouting I cannot explain to
you more how important this is guys
because if you pick up at a location and
you are not prepared it looks very
unprofessional and very unorganized yeah
you just save a lot of time and then
ensure that you are sets up before the
model and lives that's very important
because it's the model arrives and if
they still need to wait half an hour or
an hour maybe you just first set up the
lights and things like that
you are waiting stings very precious
time for your clients as well for the
model yeah it's the worst thing if
you're a model and arrive the studio or
location and you have to wait for an
hour or sometimes I've waited for two
hours and it's just like you're stealing
people's time and it's so unprofessional
yeah so that brings us to tip number two
and secondly guys when the model arrives
make them feel comfortable yes that's
very very important you tell him why yes
because remember not all the models that
you'll be shooting with will be
experienced models for example some
might be very near it might even be
their first job that they are going to
so they will be very nervous and anxious
and even though they know maybe what is
expected of them remember the first time
when you for example that is sheets you
were nervous too
so it make them feel comfy say some
background music maybe discuss the
reference images again discussing the
stuff and how the routine and the shell
of the day will look like puts them a
little bit more at ease by then
yeah be very friendly when they step
into your studio or when you just see
them for the first time ask them hey do
you want a coffee or tea yes I just love
photographers that ask me that question
yeah and even sometimes when I do a
location sheet for example I will take
the model and the assistant or even if
we are a coup or something I won't get
them to go and have coffee quick and we
will discuss some things over coffee as
are you studying at the moment are you
working what work are you do remember
don't be too invasive and ask too many
personal questions but asking a little
bit about them will also make them feel
important and yeah if you have a better
relationship with the model then the
photos will look a lot better as well
because then they feel more comfortable
with you three all right guys so now you
start your photo shoots and what you
usually do is now you taste your camera
settings and your licensing since that
right please don't just pick up your
camera and start shooting away
communicate with the model yeah just
think of the model first okay no nipping
stand there and start posing for half an
hour and giving you all these nice
facial expressions and stuff sorry sir
madam Daniel it is the light settings
first and I'm going to take one camera
sitting so just stand and relax I will
tell you in these thoughts but yeah most
of the professional models they will
know what you're doing right but the new
models they won't have any idea when I
started you know I went for em like just
didn't like them you know doing my
posing and then after 30 minutes or 40
minutes it like okay Daniel I think
we've got the settings let's start the
photo shoot I thought we already done
okay guys and then another important
important notes but this is much
probably the most important thing that I
can tell you is to keep communicating
with your model remember after the first
few shots you'll immediately know if the
model is getting the
and giving you the correct person stuff
that you want and please don't get up
and solve it you are not giving me what
I want this is not the right way that
you are posing and things like that if
they're not giving you what she wants
get out there to them show them the
pictures first of all that so they know
what they look like right now and then
tell them something like you bet on
looks very nice and this purse is very
nice but maybe try and do a little bit
of this and pose like this and re thing
show them some ways
don't be neat yeah you have to build
them up don't break them down with
negative stuff all the time so when you
go to them and say hey I love your eyes
in this one I love your your hand or
pose or just give them something right
yeah and then you go on to explain hey
maybe you can change this a little bit
like this or so then when they do the
right pose or right expression then you
just tell them great job now you're
doing this is what I want awesome and
then you'll see their confidence just
grow yes remember you are the mirror
they don't have a mirror in front of
them to know what they look like there
is a thing like over communicating or
over complimenting someone don't be too
invasive or you know it's very clear for
experienced models like for me to see if
photographers has this habit of great
good right good
good great awesome great great it just
happened you know there's no real
meaning behind it I just I don't like
student photographers like that I don't
like the sugar photographers like Nikita
when she's seeing a really good shot
good pose he's like right I love that
keep it keep it keep it all right let's
move on okay
so mix it fine and photographers
you also have lace remember it's not
only the model that needs to move around
or the can move around except for if
that is the job requirement so it's a
client's one sheets sheet from the
Front's for example like e-commerce
commerce is you can move it around a
little bit see from this angle with a
little bit to the left shoot from that
angle and stuff yes you do that's mainly
at the end of a photo shoot when you
have the specific shots that you wants
it you play around at the end a little
bit more but when shooting on location
and the client gives you a little bit of
freedom to shoot different angles and
stuff do that move around move around
the model and shoot from different
different directions and different
angles so six number six okay so second
last step guys during your parachutes if
you're doing different assets remember
you can also change up the music a
little bit suit that specific look if
you're doing for example a sixty
stylesheet' play some sixties music
if you're doing a very vintage foul
business look you can even put up some
jazz music sometimes these music just to
get the mother into that field yeah the
right music just really helps them to
get into the the whole feeling of the
clothes and everything yeah is the worst
thing if you don't have any music at all
and it's just why yeah is the worst
thing and remember when you're doing
photo shoots guys depending on the job
requirements for the clients please say
breaks in between when you get to three
hours that you've been shooting non-stop
you do get tired and you do tend to lose
some focus okay so take a break have
something to drink
have something to eat just re-energize a
little bit and then the next scene three
hours will be fine
yeah experienced models will probably
ask you hey let's take a break sure but
new models they wouldn't try an
impression they'd not sure if they can
or not sometimes they'll just be quiet
and then you just see the energy is
dropping so just ask hey are you okay do
you want to take a break and then
probably say yes the sake of Ray and
then take a break yes so that brings us
to tip number seven okay so for new
photography remember they are a lot of
editing programs out there but the based
one is still a dull
furnished quite far why because Adobe
Photoshop is used on most of your
professional photographers and it also
gives you the best quality images of the
editing yeah so if you're starting out
it doesn't matter what type of
photographer you are or want to be you
need a good editing software program so
start early with Photoshop so you really
get the hang of it and we'll also add
the link in the description down below
so be sure to check that out and then a
bonus tip have some fun guys I know that
a lot of people say that if you laugh
and stuff it's not very professional
things but remember you need to have a
balance have fun
love be in a good mood because that will
automatically flow over to your model
and the people around you when you
having a good sign they also have a good
time and then you'll get the best
pictures yeah that's true the worst
thing is to work with somebody that just
are again and they just suck the energy
out of the whole photo shoot and it's
just a worse job so if you're positive
if you have that nice kind of
life-giving energy and you come to this
shooting you're like hey guys then it
just changes the whole feeling even the
models they just feel like ah I can do
this thing and they give their best for
you as well so that the pictures it
comes out great
yes alright guys if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and make
sure to click the bow so that you don't
miss any of the next videos and that's
it right all right you guys subscribe
to pick the bell so you may need it okay
guys we are doing a moral shoot
you